[Musique]
le gouvernement de l'alberta prévoit un
déficit de plus de 18 milliards de
dollars dans son budget de 2021 22
présenté hier par le ministre tristesse
le gouvernement conservateur ne prévoit
plus de date pour retourner les
équilibres budgétaires
est-ce que l'alberta fait les bons choix
avec nous pour en parler ce soir
l'économiste david caron gestionnaire
des études au centre collégial de
l'alberta et daniel béland directeur de
l'institut d'études canadiennes à
l'université mcgill
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir bonsoir
la route sera de toute évidence très
longues heures pour rétablir les
finances publiques en alberta d'abord
est ce que le gouvernement de jason
kenney donné le bilan d'abord fait les
bons choix
je pense qu'en fait on a décidé cette
fois-ci de pour faire les choix
difficiles donc on repose ça plus tard
des choix qui vont devoir être et je
pense peut-être qu'on espère que les
prix du pétrole vont remonter vont ils
ont remonté un peu depuis le printemps
dernier où s'étaient écroulés mais ça
reste quand même des prix moins élevés
qu'ils étaient avant 2014
on a eu une baisse importante des prix
du pétrole amir en général je pense que
c'est un budget qui innovent pour et
c'est un budget qui ensuite ne crée pas
de nouvelle taxe alors que je pense que
l'alberta a besoin d'une taxe de vente
provinciale c'est la seule province au
pays qui n'en a pas et pour des raisons
policiers qu'on décide de prendre ce
risque là le risque électoral dire aller
de l'avant mais je pense que les
économies ce trop vous dire que
l'alberta a besoin d'une taxe de vente
provinciale et est en général deux
d'avoir plus de revenus parce que les
revenus pétroliers ne sont plus ce
qu'ils étaient david caron qu'est ce que
vous en pensez mais c'est plusieurs
années qu'on le mentionne comme quoi la
bertone avantage fiscal assez important
par rapport aux autres provinces
c'est toujours vrai 3000 $ par habitant
grosso modo que la province ne récolte
pas en taxes si on compare avec les
autres provinces soit en éclats l'autre
province la moins taxés alors ça serait
un 10 milliards si on devait utiliser le
même système fiscal que
la province après ça que le stand
plusieurs d'entre eux se seraient
insatisfaits que la province pour aller
chercher en termes de revenus alors
effectivement il ya de la place au
niveau 2 ou d'un niveau fiscal pour
aller chercher des revenus ce
commentaire est ce que ça aurait dû être
dans le budget d'hier
malheureusement non vu la situation
économique soit avec un peu bizarre de
mettre en place de nouvelles taxes alors
que en même temps on a un gouvernement
fédéral qui donne des prestations ou aux
travailleurs qui ont perdu leur emploi
alors qu'on donne de l'inde donc vos la
subvention salariale ça soit un peu
bizarre d'avoir une province qui
augmente ses taxes qui va chercher plus
d'argent au niveau des contribuables
alors que de l'autre côté on a un
gouvernement fédéral qui donne plus
d'argent aux contribuables
alors ça c'est vraiment double sens et
serait pas été pertinent à l'heure
actuelle est pour vous je regardais et
la note des économistes des banques
nationales aujourd'hui qui disait dans
leur analyse que l'alberta s'expose à
beaucoup plus de volatilité
quant à ses résultats fiscaux par
rapport aux autres provinces parce
qu'elle n'a pas de taxes à la
consommation
si c'était pas dans le budget d'hier est
ce que ça pourrait être dans le prochain
dans un an ou dans deux ans daniel
béland voilà je suis d'accord évidemment
mon collègue c'est paul c voilà le temps
de le mettre sans évidemment aujourd'hui
où cette année mon cuir ainsi qu au
moins la mettre sur pied une commission
où un comité pour examiner la
possibilité de taxer en provinciale qui
pourraient être mises en oeuvre une fois
que l'économie bon après la crise la
ville devint que l'économie s'améliore
mais je pense que il ne ne veulent même
pas en parler
donc je pense que c'est un manque de
courage politique mais le délire fait la
même chose avant sur iphone appelée
c'est un problème qui va durer il faut
en parler au moins et m inscrire à
l'agenda est celui du héros ne le sait
même pas donc je pense que c'est pour un
budget courageux il faudrait que j'aie
une kenny perdu beaucoup plus loin dans
les sondages sur le plan politique
beaucoup d'appuis ont été perdus à cause
de sa mauvaise gestion de la deuxième
vague l'aco vide maintenant le npd est
en tête au niveau provincial dans les
sondeurs en année et donc on fait pas
non plus coupées autant peut-être que ce
que des conservateurs voudraient de ce
côté de julia leigh
parce que j'ai tout gagné
beaucoup de sape de gier et de sa
stature politique vous le qualifiez
comment ce budget avec carrière ben je
qualifierais tout simplement d'un budget
d'attendre d'avoir rejoint plus d'accord
ce niveau là comme quoi ya pas de grands
changements
quelque part on fait on fait une mise à
jour économique plus que plus qu'un
énoncé budgétaire dans ce cas aussi vu
que grosso modo on dit que tous les
postes budgétaires vont retenir est au
même niveau vont demeurer dans dans ce
sens là c'est un peu ce qui avait été
annoncé l'année dernière avant lakovic
ancrer le budget de 2000 2020 cette
impression qu'on avait aussi comme
kouadio pas de gel au niveau des
dépenses en éducation des réductions de
votre éducation supérieure les mêmes
choses qui sortent de ce budget là la
différence par contre c'est qu'il
s'attendait pas à avoir un gros déficit
en même temps suite à la pandémie
alors on se retrouve avec un budget qui
est une continuité mais qui en même
temps que reflète la nouvelle situation
d'aujourd'hui et dans dans une solution
effectivement ou est ce qu'on ne peut
pas entrevoir un retour avec les
budgétaire du moins avant la fin du
monde est super ce conservatoire et je
pense que c'est surtout là pour voir qui
est le dommage de s attendait à
retourner dans une prochaine élection
avec un budget équilibré puis
définitivement cette fois le col
les agences de notation maintiennent
donc des perspectives négatives sur sur
la note de crédit sur la dette de
l'alberta qu'est ce qui doit arriver là
à partir de bientôt une fois une fois
qu'on sort de la crise ça va arriver
quelque part dans l'année 2021 qu'on ne
peut plus nécessairement compter autant
sur le pétrole que par le passé que la
situation fiscale financière semble
difficile et inquiétante on que doit
faire l'alberta donner un bel acte et je
pense que mon collègue des jeudis on l'a
bärtschi taxer ses habitants on appelle
seul avantage albertains mais c'est
devenu un des avantages son avantage
lorsqu'il ya plein de de revenus
pétroliers mais mais on est plus à cette
époque là et j'ai pas l'impression que
ça va revenir et en support très haut
niveau que ça l'est déjà été ailleurs
une quinzaine d'années par exemple un
moment où là il faut pas l'oublier
l'alberta c'est une province qui n'avait
plus de dette
il ya une quinzaine d'années de guerre
provincial - il a maintenant la dette
grimpe rapide
donc il faut il faut d'honneur plupart
évidemment je suis d'accord si paul
c'est quoi un coup de barre l'année
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait dans le coup
de barre créer une taxe de vente
provinciale qu'il faut augmenter
il faut formaté revenus et ils vont
regarder vos vidéos jean marc gasol
l'avantagé régates et on vous dit avoir
des taxes beaucoup moins élevés
qu'ailleurs au pays soit davantage mis
en scène sur le à long terme ont crû en
octobre devait pas passer aussi aux
dépenses évidemment mais aussi dans la
province et on en paie le prix
dans les cars ont l avantage albertain
tu es souvent présenté comme étant une
raison pourquoi les autorités devraient
déménager en alberta or ce qu'on voit
depuis que quelqu'un c'est une
amélioration interprovincial négative
alors au contraire se dit d à bertin qui
partent vers les autres reims canadienne
alors on peut même pas dire présentement
que l' avantage albertain est vu comme
une façon d'attirer des canadiens des
autres provinces vers l'alberta
alors si on appuie cet avantage si même
cet avantage fiscal n est plus
intéressant pour les autres canadiens
mais je pense aux falloir arrive à la
conclusion qu'il faut aller vers un
régime fiscal qui s'enlise davantage
avec les autres provinces
et quand va falloir ça se passe
probablement que ce soit pas d'ici les
deux prochaines années je vois très mal
un gouvernement le fait présentement
mais par contre peut-être que ça va
devenir un enjeu électoral ou prou pour
la prochaine élection
voilà pour des mauvais hockey voici un
nouveau régime fiscal que nous ont
proposé ça serait la façon de rapports
de ramener l'équilibré budgétaire
les albertains et moins pour les
services alors quelque part en raison
des services de très bonne qualité par
rapport aux autres car a dit c'est
souvent quelque chose qui est proposée
oui on dépense plus par habitant en
santé que dans les autres provinces
mais en même temps ça fait un impact sur
le système de santé à quel point est
accessible pour la population alors le
problème présentement c'est qu'on a des
très bons services
mais qu'on ne paie pas ouais excellent
merci pour cette perspective très
intéressante daniel béland david caron
merci et bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne i cirdi